Gary this website thing you're talking
about it sounds like a waste of money we
have the Yellow Pages like why would
somebody have to find you on the
interwebs worldwide web like everyone
uses the Yellow Pages and I was like
John everybody used to ride a
horse to work now we use a car attention
is the number one
asset Gary I'm looking right at you
again thank you for joining us today
so yeah of course um looking at your
record of early stage Investments you
know Facebook Uber Twitter I I I wish I
knew you way back then it's evident you
have an eye for understanding how
technology can digitally transform and
disrupt Industries so you heard my Spiel
at the beginning here about the
profession like how have you identified
these industries and why uh such a
strong proponent of tech adoption and
digital transformation no matter what
sector you're
in um I I'll answer a second one first
of all super pumped to be on this uh on
this panel um Logan I'm missing your
beard Tiff that's one of the best head
shots I've ever seen and Don I think you
and I could be tag team WWF Champions uh
the energy is real uh and then Super
enjoying the chat here by the way Matt
I'm like all in the trenches with
everybody here so let me answer the
second part because I think it really
matters for everybody who's listening
who might be tentative or who might not
be thinking about it the concept that I
have to answer this question in 2023
blows my mind because it was the
question I was answering in
1996 in local Chambers of Commerce in
New Jersey which looked like the
following Gary and I was like 21 and I
looked like 16 at the time so I get
where the cism came from for the
business people they're like Gary this
website thing you're talking about it
sounds like a waste of money we have the
Yellow Pages like why would somebody
have to find you on the interwebs
worldwide web like everyone uses the
Yellow Pages and I was like John every
body used to ride a horse to
work now we use a car you know the
answer to your question is if people on
average are losing $76,000 that are on
this call by not using technology and
even if that's an inflated number if the
number is a
thousand plus time you know many people
here if they used proper technology
would be able to go and see their kids
soccer game during tax season like like
this is time and money like I don't
understand like your ideology that you
hate AI or you hate technology or you
liked it better in the 80s when the kids
played outside like I'm sorry like you
live in 2023 and you're running a
business and to not use technology or
demonized technology is asinine you use
technology for everything if you don't
like technology why do you have an
iPhone if you don't like technology why
do you use Uber if you don't like
technology why do your your food with
seamless and you do all these things in
real life like why don't you use a paper
ticket at the airport you're using your
QR code like like if you're doing all
those things how on God's green earth
are you not using technology to make
more money and have more time with your
family and because you're not used to it
or you don't like it I get it I get it
like it's like you don't want another
app you don't want another you don't
want to pay the SAS fee if you don't use
I get it the problem is it's pretty well
documented that you're wrong and more
importantly if you're competitors
continue to get more efficient at this
they're going to take your business so
real quick in the chat for the 600 plus
of you how many of you are retiring in
the next five years and I don't mean
you're going to crush it and make so
much money in Bay Island I mean you're
old and you're finished and you're done
in five years how many are retiring
within the five years good so for Al
dorf and one other person okay like I
can I can wrap my head around you kind
of like mailing it in the next year or
two because you're wrapping it up but
for everyone else here when when I see
Jack at 26 years old in the chat like
what are we doing here forget about this
technology like everybody here should be
using AI every day and nobody is I know
that to be true it's that early I get it
by the way me included you know I'm
giving my own ad I'm like kind of giving
advice to myself like I really need
people to wrap their head around not
understanding how to use better tools
like look I guess I get that you can
like get a screw into you know into wall
by using a rock but like we invented the
screwdriver use it like I get that you
can eat with your hands I by the way do
that often but like but it's like the
fork exists like the concept to not use
software to make more money and have
more time for your family bananas to
me let me ask you here I think you
raised a good point what what do you
think the friction point is there like
what what do you think is the the
barrier that they're that's hard to
ideology complacency and
laziness they'd rather not put in the
work for and I and I don't say that
lightly I don't say that to anybody it's
an ideology and a demonization and a and
a insecurity that they can't learn it
without realizing they're way more
capable than they
think and and going back you ask people
like who's who's going to be retiring in
like five say 10 years is there is there
advice you might give for someone who is
retired who's thinking like you're an
accountant was your business like this
there's a lot of money in that firm is
there have you ever talked to anybody
about like future proofing their
business to say like if you're not on
technology and I'm sorry if I'm
frontloading the question but if you're
not on technology I'm laughing I'm
laughing because a lot of people here
based on the comments have a sense of me
and a lot of people don't and one of the
reasons I think I have nice Vibes
towards me is I'm not just interacting
with the Facebooks and the twitters and
the Ubers I'm like answering random DMS
at like 2: in the morning from like
small businesses that have like three
like I love people and love small
business I come from small business I
grew up in a ontore liquor store in New
Jersey um of course nobody's going to
buy your if you don't have
Tech yeah like like it's
2024 they they don't want your cell
phones in your phone and that's your
business your book of business is
dramatically less valuable if it's not
got a layer of tech infrastructure to
the people that would actually buy it
yeah like I would pay I actually not in
this sector but in a different industry
I told a friend's cousin to buy the
leading software which was like $5,000 a
month which was expensive for how small
the business was but they were ready to
sell it because I knew they could ARB
out the $60,000 investment on the exit
of the business and they
did they they literally got a million
dollar off or more because they had the
tech even though they weren't even using
it Matt they weren't even using it they
just had the license and put it so like
to your point I wasn't even thinking
this kudos to you on the
question it's 2024 Jesus
Christ listen we we we penned an open
letter Gary to the industry and it was
was it was basically about being brave
and you know obviously we're talking
about the technology aspect of it but
like thinking about working smarter uh
looking at technology to boost
efficiency profitability uh and driving
healthier cash flow increased Revenue
you name it so when you hear that 43% of
accounting professionals this is from uh
a survey that we put out fairly
scientific I I'll add they absorb that
time cost and that scope create
basically absorbing the avilable work
they've already worked like what does
that make you think about the industry
it makes me love the industry believe it
or not there's no Raz on this I'm
empathetic you know don't let my cursing
and Jersey energy right now throw anyone
off I'm deeply empathetic my father
didn't accept credit cards or have a
computer computer in the store when I
started in 1993 I'm like we we didn't
take credit cards I'm like Dad he's like
people have checks I'm like not for long
bro like like I'm like Dad we don't have
our inventory figured out he's like we
count it by paper I'm like Dad they're
stealing your managers are stealing
for like like technology is good I
understand you didn't want to pay like I
I have such an old school father Matt do
you know that my father still doesn't
wire money digitally he like still signs
the checks we have a 100 employees at
Wine Library in Springfield New Jersey
right now yeah and my father can't
vacation because on Wednesdays he has to
sign everyone's
check you know like I'm deeply
empathetic I live with an old like my
favorite person on Earth professionally
as my father and I like basically still
help him manage his business like I
understand I just also refuse to take an
opportunity and miss it if anyone is
part of that crew on this call or
listening in the future you will make
more money and you will have more time
and you will be happier if you make the
commitment no different then eating
better and going to the gym will be
better for your health news alert it's
better and like I get like I that
doesn't come natural to me all the
muscles in my body only happen the last
10 years not the prior 38 years I'd
never been in a gym in my life I drink
less soda I eat less candy I eat less
carbs all are devastating to me I want
them they are delicious but if I want
the right things to happen you do the
right things for the people like I don't
understand business people not wanting
to run a better business I understand
being hesitant because it doesn't come
natural to
you but but the cat's out of the bag
it's like I said 10 times already it's
2024 it's hard to compete without
technology and I'm not even getting into
what I need everybody else to do of what
I care about which is everybody here
should be making two to three posts on
LinkedIn a day to get customers like
we're not even getting in like what
you're talking about is like oxygen and
like getting out of bed like the
you're talking about is like step one
you don't want me to unleash on these
people
Maddie I don't know Gary you're getting
me pumped here no but I mean like like
to your point like for your agenda and
like what you want for these people both
for yourself and for them like to me
that's just like waking up in the
morning for me I'm worried about
everyone here not producing content on
social media I'm worried about everybody
here not having their website properly
I'm worried about people here not really
creating funnels that lack friction to
great business development I'm worried
about here people being complacent of
word of mouth because they've been doing
it for 22 years G you don't get it I've
been the local CPA for I'm like that's
great Don but like I promise you right
now I can start a firm in any single
place tomorrow and take tons of people's
business from here never doing the work
prior hiring a kid that's been doing it
for three years years I'm not going to
get to it but like somebody else is like
Zillow became a problem for a real
estate like like let there be no
confusion the Googles and the apples and
the Amazon they're coming for your
business
everyone you better wake
up I'm gonna pass it over now Gary to uh
our esteemed panel here and you know Don
I'm gonna throw it over to you uh and
this is GNA be a Q&A from them so don
first question from you for Gary how
about it well I think everyone's
wondering your thoughts are around the
AI to be able to rebuild the Achilles
tendon of Aaron roders have you figured
that out
yet and no
crying we lost him he's already
left mic drop it was a mic drop I
thought it was a pretty simple question
personally so he laughs he closed the
laptop on accident that's probably while
we're waiting for Gary to rejoin any
reactions from the panel on what he's
saying is there anything here he is okay
he is all
right completely unemotional when it
comes to business completely unemotional
it is my greatest strength no emotion no
ideology just execution customer first
win but the New York Jets is a very
different place for me Don that is a
very different I it took everything if I
was not contractually obligated to sign
back in there is zero chance I'd be back
in this call well my heart goes out to
you I want you to know so that was
really it was coming from the heart but
just aside from that what I want I want
to ask you so the biggest problem that I
see with within the change that needs to
happen is 100% the mindset BEC and
that's what our biggest challenge is
it's not our hands it's not our feet
it's not anything else it's what happens
between your ears and how can we help
other practitioners come with the
confidence and one of the one one of the
podcast I watch of you being curious
enough and courageous enough to take the
step so how can we help them do
that you know you know this Don for I
look at all these names right Jackie C
versus Beverly G versus Jennifer T and
the reality is it's different for
everyone right like for example one of
the things I fear is Comfort one of the
biggest enemies for us trying to help
people on this call is they're good
right they're part of a two income
family
like I can give you 30 examples that are
good loving relationship good kid like
they made like they're they've got their
together they don't need another
they don't need a Lamborghini or
Mercedes or a second house to fulfill
their insecurities they're plenty secure
they make enough money their savings
they're good the problem is technology
is either your best friend or your enemy
right it's it's like a big wave for a
surfer right either you're going to grab
the surfboard and ride it and it's gonna
be epic or it's gonna get you right and
so my could first there's many different
answers to your question one is getting
the people that are complacent
understanding that people are coming for
them that last year was great the year
before was great next year is great it's
all looking great until somebody invents
an Uber I spoke at the national black
car and taxi convention the year Uber
launched and I was an investor and it
was just kind of like it lined up I
wasn't speaking as the investor of uber
I was speaking as Gary B because I wrote
this orange book about customer service
and it went really well I just invested
in Uber and I could see Uber was
winning and I'm on stage and I'm like by
the way I did my Spiel but I'm like by
the way have anybody raise your hand if
you've seen Uber and like some people in
LA and SF and New York raise her hand
not the whole room and I went into a
five minute Spiel of like hey this might
be a
problem when I tell you they laughed at
me the same way Don that somebody right
now when I say somebody's coming to get
you and some someone sitting there and
saying I've been dominating Short Hills
New Jersey or Beverly Hill or Topeka
Kansas for 20 years Gary I love you
you're entertaining I get it but not for
me 20 years 59 clients who've always
been with me third generation families I
got the grandkid now not for me Gary and
they don't realize that like you've got
to continue to Future proof your
business with new technology because you
can get caught and I want to remind
people here that a lot of you built your
business business is by taking market
share from the person that you out
innovated with Google Adwords a website
Direct Mail working Harder by hustling
in the local area innovating like you
did that and somebody can do that to you
and so like just don't don't chill right
and and Denise is right into it with AI
like like and they're already making
moves they're already they're already
doing other things that we're all seeing
as the email comes in you're like what
are they doing now and it's like well
just stay ahead of them we can stay
ahead of them and honestly you it's
probably going to be hard to stay ahead
of big tech companies just staying a
hair more contemporary and on it than a
low state will service people well
here right just sending an email to all
your clients to talk doing a zoom like
this with all of them about how to use
AI That's like left field let me let me
give you a weird strategy done send an
email to all your clients saying doing a
Google Hangout and now this is after
three four six months of playing with AI
yourself because you can't talk out of
your ass all my clients I'm just doing a
little five minutes literally 6:15 to
6:45 30 minutes on some fun things about
AI I think we all know AI is out there
I'll show you what I've been thinking
about that 30 minutes for the 10% of
your clients that show up to the
zoom where you really just talk about AI
in general not from a CPA standpoint
point we'll make every one of your
clients that got that email
subconsciously understand that you're
staying ahead thus rendering them not to
consider to move from
you yeah well we're going to commence
polling shortly folks to be on the
lookout for those polls
um just an FYI uh Logan over to you for
a question for Gary please awesome Gary
Jin Z is starting to make money and need
accountants like what needs to change to
be able to attract and sell our services
to that
generation there's two ways to think
about it brother as you know a lot of
you get business just because their
parents worked with you right that's
real that's cool for a lot of people and
I love that I do think gen Z is sh and
Jen Alpha for sure which is a little
further away but there's some youngsters
on this call but gen Z is showing very
clear indication that they're not going
to use their parents accting
will like they're very very very very
cynical to their parents generation
there is a Generation War of Boomer
Millennial versus gen Z and it's
manifesting as a ha haa on Tik Tok but
it's showing up in business results
we're seeing the lowest uh conversion of
generational service
providing and it's a big fear for me for
a lot of people here um and and I hate
this generational stuff one of the best
please can we just stop saying jenz like
every person's different like
generalization of generations is hurting
us you know look I think this goes back
to what I was alluding to Logan I I
really do want people here to make three
or four or five Tik toks describing CPA
101 or taxes 101 you know like I think
relevance is GNA matter and I know that
people are like wait a minute I'm not
making a Tik Tok I'm like cool but go
put in CPA hashtag CPA or hasht taxes
search that on Tik Tok right now you'll
be blown away and you don't have to
dance and you don't have to make a skit
you could just talk real
facts this is a big one for a lot of
people jenzi is using Tik Tok as a
search engine over Google in a real way
and a lot of you get your business from
Google things are changing and so you
know I really really really want to make
sure that if especially for the people
here who plan on doing business for the
next 20 30 years um even 10 that they're
starting to get to a place where the
requirement of making a little bit of
content in these platforms really
matters because they're look like you
don't even need the content it's similar
to what I just said earlier creating a
Tik Tok and making 10 videos just having
it when genen Z client looks at you and
looks for your Tik Tok and sees that
you're there there's a level of
confidence that you understand um
because they're asking questions and
they're thinking about it differently
and they don't want to pay your fees if
they can get around it and into it with
AI or other things is going to be a
thing and so you're going to have to win
on people skills like you always have
and I think relevance is going to matter
and I think a little bit of content on
Tik Tok
will go a long way for a lot of people
who future proofing their business
doesn't have to go viral you just have
to show that you do it I love that point
the people skills Gary it's never going
away it's never go here's the good news
for all the AI and all the Tik Tok and
all the Gary being excited about
technology it's a human game but scaling
the humanity is what I'm trying to get
all everybody do I like that I want you
to use technology to scale your human I
want you to use technology as a gateway
drug to your human skills
Tiffany what's your question for Gary
all right Gary so for us people that we
are with you we 100% know technology is
the absolute way we have been doing our
best to be able to stay forward stay on
top of it what is that
advanced information that you would
share for those to take our businesses
that are techsavvy to that next level to
be able to get those science and start
scaling YouTube shorts is a secret
weapon for everybody here because
YouTube is the second biggest search
engine in the world and the biggest when
it comes to accounting and taxes because
most people's reading comprehension
isn't strong enough to read the long
form C content that's out there so a lot
of people are going to YouTube to watch
videos and listen to information on
making decisions YouTube shorts a short
form video similar to Tik Tok and
Instagram but if you touch tile it based
on search queries so you go and look on
Google Trends or on Google to see what
people type for how do I do my so you
make a video on some new tax law and
that's your video but you title the
video even though it's not actually
what's in the video you title it how to
do my taxes in
2024 because that's how it indexes on
Google excuse me on YouTube for search
so look this even for someone like me
who's an advanced businessman I am not
going to stay up to date on every tax
law most people know nothing about what
you guys do for a living showing
confidence or information to people is
the quickest way to get their
business and so for the advanced group
Here YouTube shorts even more than Tik
Tok or Instagram because people use
YouTube to search is a huge huge
opportunity and something people should
be looking at the other one is LinkedIn
I I can't express especially for you
three pan I don't know where you're at
on your career on this like two three
posts a day and I know that's like a
daunting number but like Zach said what
if you freeze up on video well then talk
like show a tax return show your tax
return video it and talk over it you
don't have to be in the video not
everybody is as Dynamic on film as Dawn
B here who explodes off the screen with
a double fist pump not everyone has that
you know and that's okay for people that
can write their asses off but aren't
good on video then linkedin's a
Mitzvah right uh Instagram you can post
something like a dollar bill but then
write 10 paragraphs and that's the
post you know you can you can do a lot
of you can go do AI generated content
and say make me a picture that has
$76,000 in pennies now you got an image
to reinforce what Matt wants people know
which is you're wasting
$76,000 imagine that image of like a
drillion pennies and then you
write so like there's a lot of ways to
be creative and do content but that is
required Tiff that is required this is a
Content
Warfare Gary like this doesn't take a
lot of time throughout your day is what
I'm
hearing it takes a lot of time to make
the mental jump that Don was talking
about and then it's what happened with
me with working out it's still the
hardest but it's a lot easier for me to
go to the gym this morning and bang out
my work than 10 years ago when
like it was just death literally there
was in that first year I was like I just
G to jump out the window and die I do
not want to go to the gym right and like
like and then it just becomes like right
now there's a lot of people with tech
SAS social they're listening to me
talking they're like no way they're like
I'll let my niece do that or this that
but once it becomes a habit and it
doubles your business or protects your
business you're really happy you did it
just like the people that would have
died of a heart attack that didn't I
promise you they may not know it because
they'll have to wait to get to heaven
when God tells them you would have died
if you didn't stop eating those
cheeseburgers but they will be happy
when they get to heaven and realize they
live for 20 more years because they
changed their health for all of you on
this and then everyone in the chat do
you all believe that when you do your
service for people you Sav them money by
understanding the tax law that year and
put them in a position to save money
please say yes or no real quick very
simple
question this
industry is like I understand humans
back to Dawn vers Tiff DNA parenting
environment there's variables to why
someone will feel comfortable or
uncomfortable to ask for money there's a
lot of parents that demonize asking for
money or neighborhoods or teachers or
people of influence I the reason I asked
the question and obviously everybody
responded what they responded is there's
not a lot of businesses on Earth that
can speak to saving people tangible
money that's black and white that you
can show
them right like like when I talk about
time efficiency savings this is a blind
thing you're 19 hours back made you more
money but that's a very heady
intellectual deeper understanding thing
you nobody here should be scared to ask
for money because you can literally at
the end of
it have show them that you saved it more
importantly like this is a big one just
gonna I'm sorry to interrupt your flow
Don but I'm like about like what's gonna
happen when you ask for more money than
you asked last year they're going to
tell you you're a creep like
what like you know this the biggest
issue for most people here is asking for
more money from someone that they've
been doing business with for a long
time right I don't know if you guys
heard like money costs money now like we
don't get money at zero interest anymore
like like I just really need people like
like like literally here's the
conversation let's role play Don hey
quick I'm really glad you answer my
email I just need five minutes I know
how busy you are listen I'd have to tell
you what's going on obviously we've been
doing business for a long time and I'm
really thankful for our relationship but
the supply and demand you know I'm
running my own business too just like
the business you're running I have a lot
of people trying to come in the door but
I want to do that hand-to-hand Dirty
Work that I've always done for you but
I've got so many more people coming to
want to work with me and you know full
disclosure I've been grandfathering your
price to do the work for you for so long
I'm going to need to raise it because
I'm really starting to hurt myself and
my business and I know that's not your
headache and you it may be right for you
to go with someone else who can stay
within the budget but I really think
I've earned this 20% increase on the
fees that I've been passing along okay
so now that's what you say here is
literally the answer now I'm going to be
in Reverse Don just said that to me hey
Don you we're never working
together again hang up what just
happened what happened is
you lost that Revenue but for a lot of
you was that Revenue worth it like you
can't ask for more money if you're
scared to lose
it but for a lot of you you don't have
more capacity to take on more money at a
higher money so what I just did to Da in
a lot of ways you're like good I don't
want that toxic person in my life
anymore that's not a good customer what
is more likely going to happen 70% of
the time
is Don I totally get it you've
absolutely earned it thank you or the
20% of time because the you is only
one% of time the 20% of the time is like
hey Don you're hitting me on you know
like I appreciate you called me in
September tax season's obviously April
like this year hasn't gone as well can
we do this can can we just keep it for
one more year can you can you do my
season this year at the old price and
I'm in for the following year and then
Dawn can make that decision if Dawn's
got 4,000 requests to work with her she
might say no if Don's got like eight and
she's always liked Gary she may say yes
but this concept of imagining some sort
of weird Boogeyman by asking for a
higher fee than you got paid the year
before or the last 13 years you're
allowed to raise prices you know gas
isn't 99 cents a gallon anymore these
coffees are nine bucks you want
to talk about dumb there used to be
a quarter like it's okay to
ask yeah 100 percent and I think that
again I think you guys get the
understanding of what I'm trying to show
here that client experience and that in
that last scre I was go g I'm the worst
no you're the best I'm about to say
something that's gonna help Jennifer and
Jackie can't look at this I'm
pumped on double fist like you do let's
go let's go ready lowball clients
suck you suck Jen you and Jackie suck
what I mean by that of course you don't
suck I love you this is why I'm
jumping in there is no such thing as
lowball clients you don't have to take
them there's no lowall clients they
you're a puss and a pushover and you
can't have cander you're the one that's
wrong not them their job is to pay as
little as
possible I don't know I don't I'd like
to pay I'm in business out here you know
Tiff can't have lowball clients she's
out here trying to make money they're
trying to make money I don't want to pay
you tip but guess what you don't have to
say
yes lowball clients don't suck
complaining about lowball clients when
you have full control of not taking them
that sucks
you are all 100% in control you
know who this is this is the accountable
ant this is my favorite be friend in my
little Sesame Street meets Pokemon world
that I'm building do you know why I love
the accountable ant the world especially
America has become incredibly not
accountable everything's fingers it's
the president's fault it's my boss's
fault it's the world's fault it's my
uncle's fault my parents up
everything's no no thumbs get out
of the finger pointing lowball clients
do not suck you in control of firing
them that's 100% And that's and that's
where the Mind shift has to happen like
we we we have to take that
responsibility on and I definitely for
sure have had to and you have to look
into your own soul to figure out where
that is but at the end of the day it's
true and you know when you get a new
client let's just say you get a new
client who calls up we had we had one
just last week and they're like hey we
want you to do this we want you to do
that we're a manufacturing company out
of here we're doing all this stuff I'm
like no problem tell you what we'll do a
six-month contract here it is he goes
that's out of our budget I said that's I
to you know what I respect that you're a
business owner you're going to work hard
that's fine we're not your firm people
come in here I'm like we are not the
cheapest firm around here and as a
matter of fact I prefer clients that are
not in my area to be honest with you I
would rather have people in different
parts of the country who have that value
and respect for what I do I think a lot
of times in my this is just maybe in my
area local clients are tough they know
you they see you out at dinner and they
want you're their buddy and they want to
get something cheap and it's like those
aren't the people you want they're just
not it's not they're bad people by the
way lowball clients often started as the
best because they were your first
clients that got you off the ground that
really pisses me off Don when people are
mad at the clients that actually started
their whole career and they got them on
grandfather fees and now they're mad at
them when those prop them up
there's a lot of people in here who
aren't ready to fire clients you're not
there yet I didn't fire any
client for nine years building vayer
media I ate left and right
delicious Don ate it because I had
no options I wasn't there and a
lot of people here are watching don't
don't listen to me you should charge
less get more clients right out meaning
you got to be self-aware where you are
on your journey you know what I mean
yeah
absolutely I would talk back and forth
with Gary the whole time but that's
unfair so I'm gonna just be
quiet um Gary I was looking at the time
and being respectful of everybody who's
on the call here but listen I want to
ask you one last question real quick
Matt I just want to pound this and I'll
get I promise I won't leave this huge
mindset I'm seeing it here and we're
gonna win I'm so pumped for
everyone who's in this seminar Lisa says
so confusing to me why friend and family
wants discounts they know you they want
you know them just put the mirror on
yourself why shouldn't they like why do
they want discounts because they're your
friend well why do you not want to give
them a discount they're your friend like
what I'm saying is if we all just spend
Zero Energy of being mad at our
customers
zero and take all that energy all that
yapping with your do you know who
listens to you complain other people
that
complain I promise you if we were
friends and relatives and you called me
with that dumb of like Ron he
was always trying to get a deal I'm like
say no well Gary I
need you need that 1500 bucks you want
2,000 but you'll take the 1500 so stop
being a
hypocrite take let's make a commitment
all hands in on this ignition um seminar
all hands in all collectively that we
never again all hands in that we never
again ever
again blame our customers they have the
right in a capitalistic environment like
America to ask but you have the power to
say no and if you say yes it don't
listen to where I'm at a different point
of my career now we now say no to people
who want to pay us $2 million a year to
do our services when we were estatic to
take 5,000 a month 14 years
ago so know where you're at but when you
say yes own it we people are like Gary
are you so tired and exhausted I'm like
I made this bed I'm a hungry
entrepreneur I made my bed I have to
sleep at it you think I'm gonna complain
about being tired when I'm living in my
bed that I made you've got to live in
the bed you make if you say yes you say
yes but you only have to do it that one
year you're allowed to ask for more the
next year and if they say no you're
allowed to say yes you're not a push
over do you know how many times I've
negotiated and be like I can't do it Don
Logan you're out of your mind I can't do
it for less than 30k Logan's like 20K
bro and then at 1159 59 before it hits
12 I'm like fine I'll do it for 20K I
like you Logan you shaved your beard
we'll do it this year right like you're
in full control and I don't feel like
I'm a pushover or a loser in that
situation because I didn't win that
current kind of negotiation I feel like
I was in control of making my decision
at the last minute that worked for
me and whether you give free to your
family like I see Jennifer or if you
charge them double it's you're just in
control and you're wasting a lot of
energy overthinking it based on your own
insecurities not what they're doing
wrong go ahead Maddie yeah listen I'm
gonna launch the last poll we're heading
into tax seeson renewal season so folks
I hope you're thinking about your taex
tax so we're going to get that PLL up
and running Gary I think you took the
one question I was going to ask you last
I'm I'm going to give you the lob ball
here uh I'm sure you got something to
say like what is the one piece of advice
after everything you've heard today
everything you've read in the comments
that you would give to the folks on this
call about technology running a more
profitable business sky's the
limit that this is an insular game that
you take your two index fingers and you
put them in your ears and you worry
about nothing besides you and what you
can do about what you need to do forget
about if you do not want to use
technology after the motivation that
we've done here for an hour mle off good
for you but if you get your ass kicked
in the next two or three years you
better own it and don't tell me that
it's Elon musk's fault or
America's fault or the democrat's fault
or the Republicans fault fingers
and ears you're in full control 100 100
100% in control
100 you are 100% in control okay you are
100% in control not
99 and with that you will start making
decisions that can make you much happier
and whether that's to go harder at
technology after today I'm telling you I
saw some of you jump into this I'm so
pumped the number one way to have a
happier life and a more productive life
in service businesses is never blaming
your
customer I'm so I'm so pumped we got
that in serendipitously here like
because you'll see what happens it just
changes everything you start hiring
another person you start charging more
you actually fire two people by the way
if if you can afford it because some of
you can't but no one should treat you
nasty you don't understand how much it's
costing you and I know all of you have
that one or two client that just curse
at you or you know like some you know
you're all humans you probably missed
some sort of $538 rebate somehow they
figured it out they call you in
June and you're a piece of
that do not allow anyone to be
overly nasty once in a blue moon maybe
their mom's dying from a disease you
didn't know like if somebody's proed to
you that they're a good human being and
they have a bad moment we have to have
stability and capacity for that but if
someone's consistently shown you that
they're not a nice person and they're
treating you they're paying you to beat
you up to get their he anger and hurt
out on you because you're a service
provider you fire that
customer I mean that right now I mean
again or you're where I was 14 years ago
and all of us were maybe you're in that
year one two three where you really need
it or maybe you just put your kid in
private school and like you just need it
and like that's okay because now you're
doing it for a reason I eat
constantly even at the level that I play
out because I know why I'm doing
it so this you know one big game MADD of
self-awareness is my final piece of
advice one big game of self-awareness
and self-love for yourself about
yourself
but hold yourself accountable no
excuses Matt do you know how crazy it is
how many people spend their entire life
complaining about what their parents
up as if they're not up
their kids oh my my sister's a therapist
I get I get all the skinny that locks
it's like constant it's like like what
okay but what you're 49 Johnny what are
you gonna do about it like I get it your
mom up cool everyone's mom
up like like like accountability is the
gateway to
happiness there is no bad customers
there's just bad behavior that you
created to create a bad
customer and if they're bad no no that's
you being strategic to eat some to
get to the next
place Gary I think that is a a hell of a
note to finish on um I think as you've
seen from the comments uh the best
accounting webinar people have sat on
you've stoked people up I think it's the
message everyone need to hear especially
this time of year I want to thank
Tiffany
Logan Don and Gary thank you so much for
your time and everything you've you've
told us today it's been awesome it's
been a lot of fun appreciate it and by
the way by the way just to add another
value because this goes back to like
what I want all of you to do and I'll do
this here and I did it earlier I'll do
it one more time this is my LinkedIn no
if you see me involved in
something I can help with right like you
see a photo with me with one of your
customers because I was at a conference
like I read my messages if I have to hit
them up and be like yo Dawn's the best
double her salary like I do random
I you need me to send a selfie to your
nephew I'm about that life so anything I
can ever do I love Karma points I'm
happy to put it on so awesome Gary thank
you thank you
[Music]
Gary